i am not ready
to return to that time of my life hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
we will be talking about the reprise of
y2k style and if you care about the body
neutrality movement why you should be
very
very afraid but first let me tell you
about my sponsor lily silk so lily silk
provides affordable investment pieces
with a wide product range like silk
pillowcases blouses pajamas bedding
sheets and more so you can imagine
everything with silk on their site and i
was really excited when i tried the
products myself so they've been working
with world-renowned recycling company
terracycle commit to zero waste
production so all the little scraps of
material from manufacturing actually go
into making nice silk eye masks and
little scrunchies
[Music]
all of their products are oeko certified
so this blouse is from lily silk spring
collection
[Music]
it was inspired by art deco and adopted
contrasting colors on the collar and the
cuffs
so beautiful you really feel like you're
hardly wearing anything at all feels
like i'm wearing nothing at all so light
and so comfortable and it really just
keeps my skin feeling hydrated all day
[Music]
and the one size bra fits a wide range
of bodies so the silk material is
blended with spandex and it's non-wired
and it has detachable built-in pads so
comfortable
plus the seamless design leaves none of
those embarrassing kind of bra traces
and it's really really cozy for sleep or
for day wear the material just feels
like a second skin it's not suffocating
like a sports bra it really holds you in
and provides enough support
[Music]
i also highly recommend the lilly silk
pillowcases especially for those who
have concerns about hair loss or
sensitive skin so it definitely helps me
hold a blowout because it really doesn't
get my hair all matted and it keeps my
skin from getting all creased up all of
the pieces come in beautiful packaging
so they are definitely good gifts for
your families and friends
there are so many benefits so hit up
that link in my bio to learn more and
you can pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating so as always feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and if you
are not already subscribed hit that sub
button and follow me over on tick tock
and instagram abby's kitchen join the
fam over there as we say all right i
thought we would begin by taking a
painful trip down memory lane to the
late 90s early 2000s aka the terrifying
age of y2k if you're an elder millennial
like me you might recall downloading
eminem songs on napster watching coyote
ugly on repeat and swooning over power
couple britney and jt all very wholesome
memories of my early teens that seem
innocent enough but looking back it was
kind of a train wreck time to be a young
girl i mean the heroin chic look of the
90s was still the in look and you could
not pick up any celebrity magazine that
wasn't brimming with toxic inspiration
so like the media were constantly
commenting on the apparent thinness of
it girls like lindsay lohan and nicole
richie while calling out others like
jessica simpson tyra banks and hilary
duff for being too big it's almost like
unless the celebrity was in like a very
narrow weight window their bodies were
subject to criticism and public shame
and don't even get me started on the
other completely inappropriate ways the
media portrayed or discussed women your
breasts
you seem to get furious when a talk show
host comes up with this subject now i
talked about problematic body
expectations in my 90s friends video
here but anyone who is around for this
era probably feels triggered when they
look back and not just because of the
skinny brows that literally ruined a
generation of eyebrows for life r.i.p
eyebrows
rip but anyway i digress now we know the
media's obsession with women's bodies is
nothing new and nothing old so diet
culture while rebranded is still very
much alive and well but the age of y2k
was particularly toxic and obsessed with
the thin ideal not only were we
bombarded with frail celebs and their
diet secrets but the only acceptable
body size was a size zero the body
positivity movement had not yet gained
traction in the mainstream media there
was no push for inclusivity or diversity
in fashion campaigns or runways there
was no recognition of plus size celebs
like lizzo or ashley graham and this
meant that the only representation that
i saw as a young impressionable teen was
really real thin white celebrities who
continued to get smaller and smaller by
the month so
what does that do to the mind of a young
person well folks nothing good nothing
good at all multiple studies show that
media exposure to impossibly thin
celebrities promotes the expectation and
internalization of the thin ideal as a
result young people are at a greater
risk of engaging in eating disorder
behaviors in order to meet this
unrealistic standard in fact one study
found that frequency of media
consumption was directly correlated with
increased dieting and exercise among
young girls while another prospect of
study found that young teens who made an
effort to look like the celebs they saw
in the media were more likely to be
preoccupied with their weight and go on
a diet so it's really no surprise that
research indicates a 4.3
increase in the global prevalence of
eating disorders between the year 2000
and 2018 when the obsession with fitness
was at its peak with all that said why
bring up the past like why is this era
relevant two decades later well a lot of
you maybe don't even remember this time
or maybe you were too young to read
tabloids or care but my friends the
thing about fashion trends is that they
always find a way to make a comeback so
let's take a look at some of the
evidence that the y2k thin ideal is
coming back in i bring you the low-rise
jean yep the look made famous by celebs
like paris hilton and ex-tina dirty era
and now being rocked by some of the
biggest celebrities today i definitely
was fully committed to the low rise life
when i was in high school and i am
like cringing just thinking about
putting my body into them today like
there was nothing comfortable about the
low-rise ultra strength thong combo but
for the gen z's who did not live through
the low-rise jean era you might be
thinking but abby like it's just a type
of gene it's just a style what's the big
deal well let's take a look-see shall we
exhibit a
different dream this is me
what the actual
moving on to exhibit b seem
uncomfortable
see
not great not great at all we maybe have
come a long way since the 2000s in the
world of body neutrality and body
positivity but i worry about people
feeling the need to change their body to
fit a trend whether we're talking about
the og version or the reboot when
influencers and celebrities rock the
look it's often accompanied by an
impossibly flat tummy and jutting hip
bones and let's be real most human women
do not have flat tummies and jutted hip
bones so unlike more inclusive trends
like the high-rise mom gene this little
luke is only celebrated on a body with
no visible fat which is why the
statements made in these tick tock
videos are not far from my own thoughts
when i was a teen because not only did
the imagery in the media distort my
perception of what my body should look
like but fashion trends like this and
the people who were seen rocking said
trends further reinforced it and i am
certainly not alone with my concern as
other fellow millennials have taken to
social media to express their grievances
on what it means to have this trend make
a comeback this was me in high school
you see the bone sticking out of my
chest this girl thought she was fat
because of all that bull she saw in the
media i still think that female beauty
standards are really toxic today but
did this era do a number on us how in
the early 2000s like it wasn't really
about the fashion skinny equals pretty
like that's what i grew up understanding
it's really really hard to like take
that equation out of your mind and just
like
relearn i got to a point in my life
where i was so tiny like really really
skinny
and i saw myself as fat and this is only
a tiny snapshot of a collective
experience that some of us are still
battling with to this day while some
might argue that we've come a long way
in the body acceptance movement and that
there is no way that something as
insignificant as the peridenum could
possibly undo the progress that we've
made i mean i'm not a fashion historian
i don't so but what we do know is that
the body ideal has historically morphed
and shifted every few decades it
happened so before the late 1990s heroin
chic era there was the 1980s supermodel
era which celebrated athletic bodies
with toned curves before this was the
swinging 60s which saw another phase
that emphasized impossibly thin and
slender physiques and before this came
the golden age of hollywood which saw
the glamorization of the hourglass
figure and the slim waste a la marilyn
monroe fast forward to today and the
body ideal is not so far off from the
old hollywood days thanks to the
kardashians popularizing the bbl
inspired kind of slim thick body ideal
so
when you look back in history you can
see that the body ideal and beauty
standards for women are cyclical one
minute thin is in and the next minute
curves are celebrated rinse and repeat
but folks that's not how human bodies
work some bodies are going to be curvy
in the 80s 90s 2000s and beyond some
bodies will forever be more straight
most of us can't just expand and shrink
in any kind of meaningful way every
decade so
who's to blame for these unattainable
beauty standards well it is in a large
part thanks to the fashion industry and
media who have historically told us what
to wear and who to compare ourselves to
but unlike in the early 2000s there's
now a bigger player in town social media
influencers today we do have more body
diversity and representation if we
choose to find it online and we have the
power to block or unfollow accounts that
don't align with our values this has in
turn translated into more representation
and diversity in mass media like film
music and television so well sure it's
great that we now have more autonomy
over the media we consume and can create
a somewhat safer echo chamber but it's
only valuable if these platforms
actually allow us access to this
diversity what i'm talking about is
social media censorship don't censor my
art i really wouldn't be so bothered by
this kind of low-rise trend if i saw
people in a wide range of bodies rocking
it online but according to investigative
work by the new york post a number of
plus-sized creators have claimed that
their content is consistently censored
banned and removed for
violating community guidelines any time
they post a picture or video of
themselves showing some skin i had a
reason another reason well what was the
reason i had to be one of the reasons
so whether they're rocking a bikini
sports bra or other skin bearing fashion
trend that we really see filling
anything wellness influencers feed
without contest they are often subject
to unfair penalties for posting graphic
content so
yes
their body is graphic content let that
sink in so
knowing that why would i expect that the
representation or lack of representation
on social media to be any different for
people in larger bodies just rocking the
low-rise jean trend it's also important
to mention that fashion is more than
just clothes it's a communicator of
societal beliefs and i worry about it
dragging in other distasteful phatphobic
trends of the y2k era so think about the
fat girl trope in popular culture like
shallow hal bridget jones diary monica
on friends and even part of the regina
george character arc in mean girls the
late 90s and early 2000s were cruel as
for people in larger bodies and i do not
want us ever to regress to that point
but we don't have to let it we can
resist censorship by letting these
platforms know that we do not approve
and that we want to see more diverse
bodies and diverse representation of
trends in our feeds so here's a project
for you guys please go follow plus size
creators like and comment on their
content tell the instagram gods that you
want to see more real bodies just
wearing the clothes they love whether
you choose to rock the low-rise jean or
stick to your high-rise like i
definitely will be you should feel
empowered to see
your body represented online
and on that note folks that's all that i
have for you guys today if you liked it
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below on your thoughts on
the low rise jean trend subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
[Music]